Roger I know you don't like
hypotheticals but you know I always
throw these hypotheticals at you and I
would just like to know and this is just
I don't know I'm sure you haven't even
thought about it because this is not
gonna happen okay for the record I don't
think this is gonna happen but let's say
again you got bamboozled we're talking
hoodwinked hoodwinked we're talking the
West Memphis Three
we run amok led astray led us straight
the an innocent man has gone to jail and
you do six months from now let's say you
get completely framed and bamboozled and
you get put in jail would you do you
think if that were to happen you Inis as
an innocent man you go to jail
do you think you would still work on a
best-dressed worst-dressed list for this
year from jail so let me ask you this
when you're leaving the studio tonight
today when you get popped for possession
of marijuana would you oh pardon me
I don't like these hypothetical Claire I
know let me just say regardless of what
happens right the international best and
worst dress will be produced every yea
New Year's Day the rest of my life okay
good it's a staple I think it's
necessary I think that would be the
thing that people were most worried
about if you were to go away for a long
time people would go like well how are
we gonna know who the best and the worst
rest is that's right mr. Blackwell
anymore and you go don't worry about it
they can put me in pinstripes I'm gonna
be the best dressed guy in pinstripes
well you know what they say they can put
me in jail but they can't stop my face
from breaking out one more Jim and Sam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM app
[Music]